Russia the country that gave the world's
tetris merkins you wear on your heads
and potentially the 45th President of
the United States now Russia was at the
center of a major development in the
u.s. this week Michael Flynn resigning
as the u.s. national security advisor
this coming after reports that the
Justice Department warned he could be
vulnerable to blackmail over
communications he had with the Russian
ambassador okay that's it everyone check
you office pools because if you had
communication with Russia as the reason
the first member of Trump in a circle
resigned you win that's a shame because
no money was on never set foot in a
public school or president can't stop
see melissa mccarthy whenever you speak
but interestingly the plata debacle is
just the tip of the iceberg regarding
the trump administration and russia
there were accusations swirling around
two people involved in his campaign Paul
Manafort and Carter page there's this
strong evidence that Russia hacks the
DNC's emails to influence the election
and then there's of course the infamous
leaked dossier alleging serious
connections between Trump and his
associates and Russia or as you
undoubtedly remember it the thing about
the urine fetish Moscow sex party and
look there is no hard proof yet of
direct links between Trump himself and
Russia but he does have a weird
noticeably soft spot for both the
country and its leader I was in Moscow
recently and I spoke indirectly and
directly with President Putin who could
not have been nicer
Hooten even sent me a present beautiful
president with a beautiful note by the
way it would be great if we could get
along with Russia just so you understand
that that tomorrow you'll say Donald
Trump wants to get along with Russia
this is terrible
it's not terrible it's good yeah I'm not
saying it's terrible I'm also not saying
it's good though I'm saying it's a bit
weird
you've been objectively nicer to
Vladimir Putin when you have to Meryl
Streep who I'm pretty sure is not an
infamous autocrat although you know what
now I say it if you try to achieve nail
it the woman is a sport
the poison Sun is fixated on getting
along better with Russia so tonight we
thought we'd ask what does that actually
mean what other chances of it happening
and what might we give up in the process
and I know that over here we think of
Putin as a cartoon character who staged
his photo ops where he's shirtless on a
horse or swimming like a dolphin
when emerging from the sea like a Bond
villain or wearing a old winning a
staring contest with a baby chick or
quite possibly breaking a child's arm
but but in Russia he's not some comic
book villain too many he's a comic book
hero he is genuinely popular there for
years he's even had his own pop song
[Music]
Ransome have been stuck in my head
always and I don't even sleep Russian it
it's called a man like Putin and it's
all about how women want someone like
him or don't just think about that for a
second because that means they want a
man in his 60s who have thinning hair
and it was probably about five foot five
so the manliest thing they want is
essentially Richard Dreyfuss but mean
and you'll ask for all those photo ops
what you'd really be surprised how many
Russians look at those and take them at
face value
earlier this year Beauty miraculously
recovered two ancient values from the
bottom of the ocean fortunately cameras
were on hand to capture this historic
moment never was fighting Naga religious
prescribed sea Moloch from ahoy to the
dirt en authorities glass made
interesting the poisonous by Denali at
the ocean version it does marketer
useful China so you system over
discovered oh come on not only is that
clearly but control see size
photo ops it's the same publicity
strategy as Taylor Swift and Tom
Hiddleston American Idol Swift Russia
got pootle judge have sad total judge
lose his popularity so is all the more
surprising given that from the beginning
his presidency has been shrouded in
accusations of corruption we've seen him
enriching his friends his close allies
and marginalizing those who he doesn't
view as friends using state assets
whether that Russia's energy wealth
whether it's other state contracts he
directed those to whom he believes will
serve Him
and excludes those who don't I see so
pooting Springs depend on him for their
wealth that actually explains how he
wound up once going out dressed like
this because any real friends would tell
him that Vladimir no I love you but you
cannot pull off white denim you look
like you're attending the wedding of a
yacht and the year 1991 get changed as a
friend get changed but it's not just
Putin's friends and become rich some
estimates put Putin's personal wealth
anywhere from 40 to 85 billion dollars
which would make him one of the richest
men in the world and although he
strenuously denied it nothing about his
finances adds up president Putin's
official income is around a hundred
thousand dollars a year and yet he lived
like the super-rich he has a collection
of expensive watches even his designer
track suit cost $3,000 whoa whoa whoa
whoa
what monster works out in a $3,000
Traxxas the only acceptable reason for
owning a track suit that expensive is if
you recorded the 2002 hit work it's your
name is Missy Elliott and you are not
fully aware that other clothes exist
that's it that is it I draw a line there
but for example of really surprising
wealth consider Putin's own daughter she
and her husband have holdings worth
around two billion dollars which is a
lot of money for someone who and this is
true is an academic / acrobatic
rock-and-roll dancer and if you think we
don't have footage of her in action you
are sorely mistaken
first pour and second you know a lot of
people think that the most dangerous job
in the world is prison guard or fighter
pilot but I'd like now now to put a
strong word in for guy whose job is to
throw pooping Sauter way up in the air
and then a hopefully capture you know
what know what maybe Vladimir Putin has
just been extraordinarily lucky in his
life and if so it contrasts with the
extreme misfortune that many of his
critics and political opponents have
suffered opposition leader Boris Nemtsov
was shot dead alexander litvinenko a
former KGB agent who turned on Putin
died of radiation poisoning a journalist
Anna Politkovskaya was murdered on
Putin's birthday and the activist
Vladimir Karen Mirza was allegedly
poisoned managed to survive only to be
allegedly poisoned again earlier this
year and I know that all this looks bad
but again maybe Putin had nothing to do
with any of that and just got lucky
maybe the guy has a rabbit's foot yes a
freshly severed one but still he's got
one and meanwhile other Putin
adversary's ever have a ended up
disgraced when sex tapes of them was
shown on national TV or leaked on the
Internet and a sex tape doesn't even
need to be real as this man Karl Hatcher
who works for the US State Department in
Russia discovered a few years ago last
month this undercover video of Hatcher
was posted on a Russian internet site
complete with background music Hatcher
is seen in a Moscow hotel room in his
underwear with the lights on
then the lights are out in the room and
a man and a woman appeared to be having
sexual relations on the bed Hatcher told
us officials this is a fabrication okay
now that is obviously ridiculous but I
do actually have some questions here one
if someone releases a fake sex tape of
you do you watch it and - what if the
fake you is better at sex than the real
you
and the only reason I ask this is I'm
currently talking about putting on
television so I'm expecting my fake sex
tape to come out any moment now
and I'm just I'm just interested I'm
just interested that's all through him
has carefully created an atmosphere in
Russia but he's extremely hostile to any
opposition standing up to him can mean
being targeted by trolls and not just on
the internet when garry kasparov spoke
at a political opposition event he was
interrupted and this is true by radio
controlled flying dildo and no uh I have
to say I kind of respect that visa that
takes real imaginations initiative and
planning
now what electing president is what
liberal politician Ilya Yashin claims
happened to him according as adult going
eggs colors of the blood models of the
girl from my property was no vehicle no
honey it'll today
[Music]
put a meerkat a liitle oh look I do
understand being mad at someone who is
on your car but for the record
parents walking by are not actually
going to be offended because if you have
a child your visceral response to see
someone other than your own kids taking
a dump in public is not my
problem not my problem
so to recap 13 may or may not have
stolen billions of dollars and may or
may not have been involved in the
intimidation or assassination of his
opponents there is so much that people
suspect but can't quite prove in the
same way that I suspect Putin's genitals
are just a fist covered in thorns but I
can't entirely say for sure I'm 98% I'm
just not quite there but here is what we
can say about Putin without a doubt he
among other things annex Crimea imposed
severe fines and long prison terms on
protesters propped up the brutal Assad
regime and signed a harsh anti-gay
propaganda law which many Russians
supported which might actually not be
that surprising when you consider they
see like this on state-sponsored TV
so soon Reba the Sodom and Gomorrah were
burnt with the rain of sulfurous fire
from the heavens since that time the
real name of homosexuals just so you
know our dear TV audience is not gays
but sodomites God does not tolerate the
filth and sin that may consume the
entire world
we need to resist what to stay alive Wow
now to give you just a sense of how
anti-gay Russian TV is their most
popular makeover show features five
straight guys and is called vest jacket
looks fine so in a nutshell that is
Russia under Vladimir Putin and our
president wants to get along better with
him and I'm not saying that America
hasn't regularly cozied up to regimes
with hideous human rights records I will
not mention names but let's just say
that Saudi Arabia knows who they are
but but there is something truly
alarming about
how easy chums makes this all sound if
our country got along with Russia that
would be a great thing wouldn't it be a
wonderful thing frankly if we actually
got along with Russia wouldn't it be
great if we actually got along with
Russia wouldn't it be nice if we
actually got along with Russia wouldn't
it be good wouldn't it actually be
wonderful would it be nice would it be
nice wouldn't it be nice if we actually
got along as an example with Russia I'm
all for it
sure yeah and it would also be nice if
you could walk right up to a bear and
hug it that would be really really nice
but unfortunately it's not that
easy
negotiating anything with Putin is going
to be way more difficult than Trump
Trump seems to think who to spend his
early life as a spy for Russia in East
Germany where he mastered manipulating
foreigners and I'm not saying that Trump
isn't at his level I'm just saying
what's what happened last year when Bill
O'Reilly tried to game out how Trump
would respond to Russian planes buffing
US warships I would say do not do that
that's provocation that's something that
you're not supposed to be doing but if
he did it if you divisor you to do on
many you'd have to shoot one of those
planes down I I may have to do something
which you would hate to do but this is
something I wouldn't want to do but I
would say Vladimir don't do it let's go
come on we're going to have a good
relationship don't do it but is just
embarrassing he is using the
tone of a dog owner failing to stop a
spaniel peeing on the rug
Ruggles don't do it let's go come on
waggles we're going to have a good
relationship
don't do it one don't do it don't know
undefended the thing is hump have
already given Putin something absolutely
massive and he may not even realize it
yet let me explain
Putin is actually a little bit weaker
than you think at the moment his economy
is struggling which is not great news
for an autocrat who may have stolen
billions from his own people but he is
still very popular in task because he
routinely deflects criticism on to the
US and not just to dodge blame but to D
legitimize our ability to claim the
moral high ground Russians love it when
America points the finger at him and he
just points it right back
for instance when he was asked a few
years ago about suppressing dissent in
Russia he immediately changed the
subject to problems in America but I
blame until you believe that everything
is perfect now look we know you're
demanding if your number is really funny
there would be no problem Ferguson right
no there would be no other problems of a
similar nature v there would be no abuse
by the police warning this is the same
case in Russia a lot of problems yeah
but not all problems are the same it's
not comparing la-la-land and Academy
award-nominated movie with glaring flaws
to the Human Centipede a thing that
barely counts as a film yes one movie is
people sewn mouth to anus but you know
Ryan Gosling looks at his feet when he
dances so it all evens out in the end
this message that you know if things are
bad here just know that they are just as
bad in America that is a key Putin
technique Russian state media spends a
good part of last year insisting that
the u.s. election was rigged and they
did this for a clear reason what does
the Kremlin want to put in Russians
heads there is no real democracy in the
world doesn't work this will be the
opportunity to show that hey they have
been to the same thing there is no
difference and we're no worse than they
are
yes exactly so that is the official line
your wish it everything never
try for a better world's because it
doesn't exist that is not only bleak I
think it's also the working title of
every Russian novel ever written
you know what you would expect
America's elections are rigged to be a
standard Putin line
what changed last year though was that
he had a major American candidate saying
the exact same thing and if you think
that that played into Putin's hand
imagine how happy he was to then see the
President of the United States take his
moral equivalence argument and just run
with it
Putin's a killer a lot of killers get a
lot of killers where you think our
country's so innocent do you think our
country's so innocent I don't know of
any government leaders that are killers
and then take a look at what we've done
to holy
the only way he could found any more
like radomir Putin is if he said all
that in a $3,000 Traxxas Trump
is basically the propagandist of Putin's
dreams and who knows why he is acting
this way
maybe he's compromised maybe he's an
idiot but since the President of the
United States won't stick up for this
country I will America and Russia are
not the same and don't get me
wrong
America has had and continues to have
endemic problems that need fixing that
might as well be the title of this show
but hold on though hold on did our
elections have some flaws but they are
not rigged our human rights record is
far from perfect but it does not compare
to Putin's Russia and our press is at
least currently free enough that I can
routinely do this Donald Trump America's
wealthiest hemorrhoid America's walking
talking brushfire wrong burning in
manful and ill-fitting suit full of
chickens coming home to roost
Twitter's is made manifest this Fengtian
circus peanuts a racist voodoo doll made
of discarded cat hair a clown made of
mummified foreskin and cotton can't
upload our piece of candy corn in a wig
made of you medical jaws of a clear
plastic bag filled with cheeseburgers
and Confederate flag belt buckles an old
piece of luggage covered in cheese with
a kidney drop on the Florida super car
he is basically what happened if the
secret gets into the wrong hands
I've talked a lot of has not had me
murdered yes yes there is still time the
problem is though Trump has already
given Putin a lot without realizing it
but Putin wants more experts say that he
likely wants an end to US sanctions for
us to endorse his pro-assad position in
Syria at eleven a m-- weaken NATO and to
recognize his annexation of Crimea all
of which will be against American
interests and values but there seems to
be a genuine danger that is unchecked
Trump may trade any or all of that away
in exchange for getting along better
whatever the that really means so
someone needs quickly to get into
Trump's ear and educate him in how
realistic getting along better with
Putin actually is and unfortunately our
capital cowboy cannot do it in 30
seconds so we've put together a quick
explanation guaranteed to stick in
trumps mind in the catchiest possible
form shitty techno music
[Applause]
no no no do not on my car that is
weird it's so weird if anything it might
be the weirdest part of this whole story
please don't on my car stop please
don't do it I'm sorry you would mean you
were telling the president about Putin
go